a herd of goats has been let loose on
the city's fields and hillsides to chew
away at grass and brush that can serve
as fuel for fires and they're also
providing lessons and a few Thrills to
some young City students here's
correspondent John Blackstone with more
for Hungry goats California's unusually
wet winter has produced a bounty of
green
but this herd is not Grazing In the
countryside instead they're on an urban
Hillside in San Francisco
eating their way across concrete
Terraces and scrambling on cement slopes
all under the care of Genevieve church
I'm the executive director of City
grazing I'm the most glorified goat Herd
on the planet yeah in all Her Herd
numbers 128 and the city is their
pasture we are a non-profit and we take
goats all over San Francisco and some of
the surrounding Bay area to eat down
fire hazard as we are here at Malcolm X
Academy the goat's main job is fire
prevention because all this green will
turn brown and dangerous in California's
dry summer
don't have lunch but here at an
elementary school Malcolm X Academy the
goats can also be educational the
students get to come out here and see
this and it's a really tangible example
of what we do and why we do it Rebecca
Poland is landscape manager for the San
Francisco Unified School District the
goats she says provide a lesson in
sustainability it's a really circular
ecology the goats eat the grass and you
know they digest the grass and their
waste is really great for the soil which
helps with erosion and so over the long
term instead of slowly degrading the
land we're regenerating the land you
must have maintenance staff that could
come out here with tools and cut all
this down in a few hours probably you
know some of the area is sloped so
that's a little tricky to do and then of
course once they cut it all the grass
would be remaining here and the goats
will eat it so it's actually more fire
safe than it would be if we did it with
the cruise what other kind of fire
prevention could bring this much joy now
why would a goat eat some grass from a
hand on the other side of the fence line
when there's all this grass over here it
could be more delicious who knows what
that child might put through the fence
so they are always opportunistic little
Beasts for a special ed teacher Teresa
Bryant the goats are a gift to the
students here now the kids don't get out
in the neighborhood so they really need
to see the goats in the neighborhood
they enjoying something live not in the
country but right here in our city in
our neighborhood but it's a neighborhood
and a school that sometimes has to
struggle to find beauty Sarah aldama is
school social worker at Malcolm X
Academy where every student comes from
typically low income with families of
color born and raised multi-generational
families within our community what are
the challenges various challenges within
just attendance showing up to school and
having a consistent routine sometimes is
hard do you think attendance will be
pretty good this week while the goats
are in the yard it's exciting there
definitely excited to be here with the
goats
it is likely to take the 25 goats on
this job a week or so to finish the
cleanup how much can a goat eat in a day
as much as it wants it's a perfect job
for an animal that's known as a big
eater but contrary to popular belief
goats won't eat everything
they don't like lavender they don't like
Sage they don't like Rosemary they don't
like eucalyptus they won't eat burritos
you were telling me they don't like
burritos people like to try to feed them
their leftover food sometimes we do ask
please don't feed the goats with plenty
of what they do like here and surrounded
by admirers there's just maybe a goats
Field of Dreams
for CBS Saturday morning John Blackstone
San Francisco
kind of hungry now don't feed the
burritos a big salad